[Music]
in this video
we're going to walk through how to
update your google cloud billing account
and payments profile settings for
self-serve accounts
your billing account and payments
profile work together
the billing account tracks the costs
incurred by all attached projects and
defines who pays for the resources
it is connected to a payments profile
which stores your payment instrument
information
and defines how you pay for charges both
your billing account and payments
profile store several pieces of
information
for the selection of items highlighted
in this video some can be changed after
initial creation
and some cannot to change those items
you will need to create
a new billing account and or payments
profile we will now cover how to update
changeable items using the cloud console
get started by heading into the console
then head to the navigation menu in the
left hand pane
choose billing then use the drop-down
menu to select manage billing accounts
first we will walk through changes that
can be made to a cloud billing account
including display name and organization
in order to perform these tasks
you'll need to be a billion account
administrator on the billing account
select the billing account you want to
update this will open the overview page
in the left-hand nav choose account
management
at the top of the window you will find
the option to change the organization
you will also see an option to rename
the billing account
this name is what users see displayed on
the console when enabling or changing
billing on projects
next we will walk through changes that
can be made to a payments profile
including billing address payment users
and payment method
a payments profile can be linked to
multiple payment accounts across google
products such as google workspace google
cloud google ads and
more so keep in mind that changes will
apply to all linked payment accounts
in the left-hand nav click payment
settings
in the payments profiles section you
will see an option to update the
business name and address
this mailing address is the legally
registered business address that gets
printed on invoices
in order to change the billing address
you must have edit payment profile
permission
or admin with all permissions for the
payments profile
note that permissions for the payments
profile are set by visiting
pay.google.com
and not using the google cloud iam
service
next scroll down to the payments user
section
follow the link to manage payments users
where you can add
delete and update payment user details
including contact information
and notification settings in order to
perform these tasks
you must have the manage user's
permission or for full capabilities the
admin with all permissions role for the
payments profile
finally to update the payment method
navigate to the payment method page
using the left-hand nav
here you can update your primary payment
method and add new payment methods
in order to manage payment methods you
must be an admin with all permissions
for the payments profile
head over to the documentation to check
out more details
[Music]
you